branagh please tell us about your latest
project sacred journey of the heart
sacred journey of the heart is a
documentary film about the
transformative power of the heart it's
about the power of the heart to really
create a different reality and I was
inspired to make this film because I
wanted to provide a missing link that
was present as I felt in so many of the
film's on transformational growth in
consciousness which is about the heart
itself not just the mind and the mind
and the ideas and affirmation but I
wanted to contribute a missing piece
that showed when we bring the most
powerful organ of our body which is not
just a physiological organ but energetic
in alignment with our mind then we can
really create a very powerful
transformation within and without and
also in connection with the earth so the
film was brought out from your own sort
of life awakening that happened what was
it 2001-2003 your life sort of showed
some signs of changing and then you
developed a new way of sort of living
well I was living the what I call the
ladder of success I was in corporate
America as a financial professional
climbing that ladder of success right up
to the top very very quickly and I was
have been 15 years in a major financial
institution and then that company was
acquired by another one and I got laid
off just because it was a reduction in
force so then I went got another job in
finance that company folded after nine
eleven a third time around I found
myself looking working in a job for the
first time in my life that I didn't love
because I love being in finance and
banking I met interesting people and
then I thought the universe is telling
me something three jobs in three years
and here I have to make a choice because
I could have kept going on and I said
now it's a choice because I have some
gifts that are all based on heart in
communication and am I going to keep
going after this and making more money
and getting more possession
the more Fame out there or am I going to
share the true gifts that I came into
this life to help people with which is
how to heal and how to really connect
deeply with the emotions and the mind
when you told people about this
that you were making in your life um
what was just a response every everybody
to a person's that are you crazy you
have it all you have the car the family
the lifestyle the trips to Europe the
the everything is set your life is a
trajectory that you know what is going
to be like I would have been financially
secure the rest of my life but I said
you know what I this is not what I'm
here for and I have to take that leap
off the cliff and I don't know where
it's going to take me so there wasn't
any single person my husband of 20 years
at the time saying you know go for it
people were just telling me you're crazy
but there was something inside me that
said I have to do this and I can't
explain it so I just quit trying to
explain it and I did it
you